a double security fence surrounds a 105
foot diameter flat concrete platform
and a close analysis of the approach
Road reveals this is no ordinary
structure
where the road comes into the compound
the Shadows really give the impression
that the road doesn't stay flat but
actually dips down
is this compound hiding secrets that are
somehow related to a more Sinister
purpose military analyst Carlo Munoz
finds some historic images that seem to
confirm that this rural landscape
conceals a terrifying secret the remote
location the security perimeter what
looks like an underground bunker is the
launch site for a nuclear missile
he classified military records confirmed
this location was one of a series of top
secret bunkers